you know with inflation being so high
right now we know it impacts all of our
viewers and so we've started a
partnership with smith's to help gift
you a good day let's take a look how i
surprised a lucky smith's shopper and
gifted her a good day
inside smith's on east lake mead parkway
i'm matt yolanda hi how are you i'm
doing pretty good good do you mind if i
talk to you about grocery prices sure
she says she drives up from boulder city
to find better grocery prices do you
really travel to find good grocery
prices yeah
why is that important right now every
cent counts especially when you're
trying to to pay off bills and stuff
little did she know she was in for a big
surprise eight news now is here at
smith's today
and uh we're partnering with smith's and
we would like to gift you a good day
and we'd like to help pay for your
groceries thank you would that be all
right if we gave you a gift card for
some groceries today that would be
fantastic oh good thank you so much oh
you're so welcome
i had a great time surprising yolanda
and you never know you could be next
keep an eye out for the good day team
and watch good day at the same time on
monday where we're gifting someone else
a good day and helping them out with a
tank of gas